all right I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
Americans alone that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now here's a troubling statistic flagged
by The Economist Bryce ward in the
Washington Post Americans spent 38
percent less time with their friends and
extended family just over the last
Thanksgiving weekend and in the past two
years and they had in the decade prior
this occurred
even more disturbing the trend lines
towards social social isolation were
worsening even before covet began
between 2014 and 2019 the amount of time
we spent with friends decreased in the
time spent alone increased by more than
it did after the pandemic began
according to the census bureau's
American time use survey between 2010
and 2013 the amount of time the average
American spent with friends was stable
at about six and a half hours per week
then in 2014 time spent with friends
began to decline
so what accounted for the drop in
in-person socializing well here's an
educated guess in 2012 Facebook went
public and bought Instagram and by 2014
the social media company was a dominant
force in American Life
Five Short Years Later by 2019 the
average American was spending only four
hours per week with friends a sharp 37
percent decline from 2014.
so the increasing use of social media
also political polarization online
pornography all contributed to Americans
move inward
of course coveted restrictions only made
this growing trend of loneliness worse
now there are many culprits out there
Chief among them are brazenly corrupt
Public Health sector their media lap
dogs and blue State Governors and Mayors
who love power and control and of course
they didn't give a rats you know what
about what they were doing to our
society
so of course time spent alone went up in
time with friends went down
in 2021 the average American spent less
than three hours per week with friends
that's down 59 compared to 2010 to 2013.
now we all know whatever our background
how important friends are for just so
many of us their family
when I was young I was essentially an
only child because my brothers were so
much older that meant my friends from
like field hockey and softball from
around the neighborhood
those relationships were formative they
were crucial to my development
young people especially they need good
friends
it's heartbreaking and it's infuriating
frankly to see what our government did
to harm mental health with coven rules
and restrictions especially to the young
now compared to 2010 to 2013 the average
American teen spent approximately 11
fewer hours with friends each week in
2021 that's a 64 percent Decline and an
additional 12 hours alone that's a 48
percent increase of being alone
now in his famous book bowling alone
Robert Putnam pegged a good chunk of our
Civic decline to television and today
it's really not cars or suburbs or
capitalism that's separating us it's our
obsession with constantly monitoring all
manner of social media
and when we're not doing that we're
streaming shows on our phones or our
tablets in our rooms often alone
I enter these apps and left feeling more
anxious spending five to six hours a day
feeling more depressed and really having
a corrosive sense of self specifically
about my own body as a young female
teens are not really told that those are
the possible harms when they enter these
apps so you experience these negative
kind of impacts on your mental health
and you I didn't really understand what
was happening and it caused Great issues
down the line that I know a lot of teens
experience
MLM case smart insights there now the
great irony is the more connected we are
in many ways the less connected we are
to real people
and it's only going to get worse in the
metaverse which is more realistic fakery
to keep the masses fat and happy and
numb to the world that's spiraling
around them
now all this adds up to creating a
society that's more anxiety ridden more
depressed less compassionate and in some
cases more violent
if you spend a lot of time on your own
you're more likely to engage in
unhealthy behaviors so you might smoke
more you might eat unhealthy Foods you
might get more stressed because you
don't have somebody comforting you and
supporting you high rates of loneliness
are correlated with more aggressive
behavior more paranoid Behavior they're
also linked to violence extremism
now a former Virginia state trooper who
had met a teenage girl online you may
have seen this story then traveled cross
country to get her and then killed her
family on Friday in California when he
was trying to get her
now police say 28 year old Austin Lee
Edwards pretended that he was another
teenager while he was talking with this
girl on the internet
the predatory Act is called catfishing
he tried to take off with the teen but
police ultimately tracked him down and
shot him dead
now the sick thing is that he probably
thought in his own warp way that this
was some great American love story
because it began
online
but he was just another loner unnoticed
by a society that increasingly seems to
Value those who ignore basic truths of
human existence
like the fact that every major religion
teaches that human beings are better off
and happier when they're in a family
connected to a community and engaged in
works of service
we're not meant to live by ourselves
it's one of the great tragedies of the
20th century that feminists work so hard
to ridicule and reverse all the things
we knew to be true about basic human
biology and just human life
they assured women that the sexual
Revolution was going to make everybody
happier
they were told that well childbearing
was oppressive religion was patriarchal
and old Norms were inhumane
some even argued that we could invent
our own definition of a family
while the image of the nuclear family is
often held up as the ideal and only form
a family can take whether or not that's
true seems to vary by social group and
region it's important to remember
whatever form shape or size it takes we
have the power to Define what family
should look like for ourselves
now much of this was a lie and now
activists who proudly declare themselves
to be the secular Crusaders they've
merely replaced the tenets of organized
religion with their own rigid Dogma
it's kind of a mix of socialism
transgenderism climate alarmism it's a
new Orthodoxy that has its own rituals
its own hierarchies its own flags and
magic words
hi my name is Johnny and I use he him
pronouns hi and I'm kanji and I use Chi
her pronouns one of the things I want to
do is make sure that I create as an
inclusive environment as possible
diversity equity and inclusion is about
embracing all differences
and we can do that while amplifying the
needs of underrepresented individuals
welcome to Zombieland
yet today the threat to our communities
and families isn't just coming from ivy
league profs and government officials
but also from our corporate leaders
look if we want well-adjusted kids who
are socially aware with better values
we're going to need to be parents who
stand up to companies like Disney and
Apple
and for that matter any business that's
profiting off the sexualization of our
children
our leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda I don't have to be
afraid to like let's have these two
characters Kiss let's in the background
like I was just wherever I could just
basically adding queerness
well our political system trusts that
the people trust the people to fill
their role as interested citizens good
family members and honest workers
being an American is not supposed to be
a spectator sport we're all expected to
help make this country work
and when Americans are trained to stay
home paid in some cases to stay home to
watch the world on screens and just do
what they're told
our Republic is actually at risk
for decades social conservatives have
warned that our freedoms our whole
system of ordered Liberty rests on The
Virtue and diligence of the American
people
those qualities are threatened by the
loneliness that is the direct result of
actions taken by cynical businesses as
an in different politicians
it's a major reason why we need a
political movement that promotes
judeo-christian values and empowers the
American people and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else